hey you so nice of you to join us we
want to tell you about something that
changed ktz kazak forever KZ Kazar
started out as a small scale passion
project but creating animated science
videos that are free for everyone
doesn't pay the bills damn you reality
in order to make ends meet we had to
take on real jobs during the day and
create qusar videos at night it was
tough but our dream of inspiring people
all around the world kept us going then
in 2016 everything changed
kazak's founder Philip demma had an idea
he wanted to create something inspiring
that would extend beyond the digital
YouTube Cosmos something tangible
something that would represent ktz
kazak's view of the world and our belief
in Humanity's potential for greatness
his idea the KZ kazak human era calendar
it establishes a new year zero to
include all people and cultures around
the world this New Year's hero roughly
12,000 years ago signifies a time when
humans first started working together on
a larger scale laying the foundation for
modern society and eventually our future
ahead of us the first human era calendar
was a huge success it sold out within a
few hours and inspired thousands of BS
around the globe every year since then
we've created a new edition of the human
era calendar each one more spectacular
and successful than the last it has
enabled us to grow our team improve our
video quality and research standards and
still release our videos for free for
everyone this year's calendar is extra
special join us as we conduct a series
of space experiments to see how they
would affect the development of Life
what would a creature living near an
orange dwarf look like could life still
exist after a supernova explosion and
what the hell is this join us in 12,24
and find out and of course you can also
use it to plan Humanity's next steps
towards greatness to celebrate what may
be our most glorious calendar yet we've
prepared a few spectacular limited deals
for you thank you so much for being a
part of our story and for coming
together every year to make all of this
possible